Let us introduce
the method we use
for predicting
the bucket number.
It is called-- it is a
method called classification
and regression trees.
In this case, we use
multi-class classification.
There are five classes,
buckets one to five.
To give you an example,
let us consider
patients that have two
types of diagnosis:
coronary artery
disease and diabetes.
So if a patient does not have
a coronary artery disease,
we'd classify the
patient as bucket one.
If it has coronary
artery disease,
then we check whether the
person has diabetes or doesn't
have diabetes.
If it has diabetes, then it's
bucket five, very high risk.
And if it doesn't have
diabetes, but given
it has coronary
artery disease, it
is classified as bucket three.
So this is an example in which
we only have two diagnoses
and we will state
how the method works.
In the application of Hawkeye,
the most important factors
were related to cost
in the beginning.
So in the beginning,
the classification tree
involved divisions
based on cost.
For example, if the patient
had paid less than $4,000--
so this is bucket one
classification-- if it paid
more than $4,000,
then we further
investigate whether the
patient pays less than $40,000
or more than $40,000
and so forth.
As the tree grows, then
the secondary factor
is utilized later in
the classification tree
involve various
chronic illnesses
and some of the medical
roles we discussed earlier.
For example, whether
or not the patient
has asthma and
depression or not.
If it has asthma and depression,
then it's bucket five.
If it doesn't, then we
consider a particular indicator
indicating hylan
injection, which
is an indication
of a possible knee
replacement or arthroscopy.
So if this indicator is equal
to 1, then it's bucket three.
If it's indicator is equal
to 0, it's not present,
then it's bucket one.
So let us give some
examples of bucket five.
So an example is as follows.
The patient is
under 35 years old,
he has between 3,300 and 3,900
in claims, coronary artery
disease as a diagnosis, but no
office visits in the last year.
Another example of a
category of a patient that
is classified as
bucket five are claims
between $3,900 and $43,000
with at least $8,000
paid in the last 12 months,
$4,300 in pharmacy claims,
and acute cost profile
in cancer diagnosis.
And another final example is
more than $58,000 in claims,
but at least $50,000 paid
in the last 12 months,
but not an accurate profile.
Classification trees
have the major advantage
as being interpretable
by the physicians who
observe them and judge them.
In other words, people
were able to identify
these cases as reasonable.
In other words,
the human intuition
agreed with the output
of the analytics model.